Do you guys want to know how many worlds that is?
That's like 10.
I think that's more than 10 actually.
Can I capture the game now?
I can capture the game now, right?
Wait, so I gotta stop streaming, right?
Oh, I'm streaming.
I got a little bit lost.
So, hello everybody.
Welcome to Pico Park 2.
We all have foogies that tell us what color we are.
I'm yellow.
Guys, please, I can't move.
Yeah, you were on my head the entire time.
Yeah, how's it feel?
How's it feel?
Oh my gosh!
Is something happening?
Who screwed something up?
His butt is on me.
Oh, now I actually can't move.
Actually, what if I switch between you guys?
That's good.
Here we go.
How does this work?
I think we have to do it at the same time.
Oh wait, no we don't.
Okay, I don't know.
Wait, why doesn't the health spring jump?
Yeah, why doesn't it work?
Maybe we each...
Maybe we have to do it at the same time.
There's like one for each of us, so I feel like that has to be a mechanic.
Okay.
Surely.
Okay, why don't we all get off the spring, guys?
Why don't we all...
Guys, the spring's not working.
They can't be doing this in level one.
That's how much...
Okay.
We have a method to our minds.
Okay, wait.
Wait, I think I know.
I think I know.
What if, like, I fall from here and then...
Okay, no, that doesn't work.
Okay, so if I die, right?
Hit me out.
Stop!
Guys, I don't...
There's no way.
There's no way we're tall enough.
There's like eight of us.
What if someone jumps from the top person?
Oh, that's true.
You make a tower.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
You're like a little diving board.
All right, do we have a diving board?
Guys.
Guys, this is level one, guys.
I think we've got a little...
Oh, we're cooked.
It's left.
Come on.
I'm stacked up.
Okay.
You're stacked up.
What are we...
Okay.
Keep going up, guys.
Keep going up.
Is it enough to get to the top?
Yes.
I feel like we're off by like one.
We got this.
We can make it!
We can make it if we try!
Oh my god!
No way!
Press the button!
I didn't be here the whole...
Oh!
Now they're usable!
We did have to start.
I can't believe it was that easy.
You have to jump on the button every time.
Well someone's tongue gets bumped!
Go!
We bumped!
Yippee!
That was so smart!
That only took us way too long.
We have to stack up.
Yeah guys.
Make an elevator.
I think it only does the other one, right?
Yeah.
Again?
Why is it counting down?
Is that a bad thing?
Oh it's time.
Oh no!
Into space!
We have to each...
You see the vision!
Go!
Oh my god.
No I jumped!
I'm an idiot!
I don't think it works if there's people on the heads.
Yeah if there's people on top it doesn't work.
So we gotta...
I like my role of watching like a god.
Here we go!
What?
I'm dying for red!
We have to wait for life to get to the other side!
Any day now.
Today's the day?
Okay.
Some people made it.
I'll be Bud Impressor.
Good!
My favorite bit of PicoPoc.
I'll be the last one.
I can make it.
Don't worry.
Yay!
Okay.
Where's the key now?
I got the key.
I don't think so.
Let us in!
We did it!
Can you imagine if someone fell right now?
Yeah like...
We fell like number one off the bat.
So we're gonna skip world seven, right?
Or world seven?
Yeah, seven three.
Okay we're on one, two.
Alright, good.
Seven of us.
Okay.
Dream walk makes the dream walk, baby.
Who's not doing their part?
Go, guys!
What the heck?
Wait, what just happened?
Somebody just died.
Okay, so can we like bait that?
I was impaled!
Did you blame this on me?
Okay, you can't bait it.
The box hit it.
So the box has to hit it first.
All we have to do is not walk to the left.
You mean the right?
I mean the right.
We'll see about that.
Left, the other left.
Let's go.
Push!
We need everybody to do their part.
Okay, now go left.
Push!
Okay.
Get off the box!
I want to see uncharted territory.
I'll go for it.
I will go for it if you do this.
I will go for it.
Are you for serious?
It's level 2!
It's level 1.
It's not even level 1.
Stop fighting!
I'm trying to push.
I'm not the one who died.
It was Doki.
Doki, come on.
Okay, let's go.
Push!
It's going to hit that, right?
It's not.
No!
What?
Somebody was underneath the box.
What if somebody was underneath the box?
I had the right idea.
Take one for the team, buddy.
They wear the box.
How do you wear it and people still push it?
Oh, you drop it on your head.
Drop it on your head.
I've got a little surprise for you.
Yeah, yeah, you beat me!
Go, Snuffy, go!
Oh, it works!
Yeah, yeah, she's so genius!
We are shockingly intelligent!
She's invincible!
She's wearing a bicycle helmet.
Follow me.
Nice.
Stop, stop, stop!
We need karma!
Oh, we gotta jump on the box.
Stack, guys!
Stack, stack!
We're stacking?
I'm pushing, I'm pushing.
Now you just put it in the door.
The key?
The door.
You just have to put the key in the door.
Guys...
Can you leave out?
We're doing great.
Yeah, we got this.
We're so good, maybe.
We might be gamers.
We're a bunch of Teletubbies.
We might be gamers, guys.
Look at that.
This is how we build friendship, everybody.
Oh!
What's this?
Oh my goodness gracious.
Hit it again, again, again!
Keep going, keep going!
Fix the problem!
Go, go, go!
Go!
Oh!
Ahhh!
What the heck?
We don't have to do it anymore.
Yeah, we're good.
I just wanted to...
That was too easy.
Let's do it again.
Screw the door.
We definitely messed up somehow.
You say that, we'll find a way.
What if it, like, collapses on top of us?
Alright.
We all got blood force trauma.
I feel like the skill jump is gonna hit us hard in level 2.
No, no, no.
Woah, woah, woah.
What's going on?
The platforms are moving!
Don't hit the jumpy jumps.
Don't go jump.
Jumpy jumps.
Don't go over there.
What if I go really fast?
There we go.
Oh, okay.
Use me as a stepping stool.
That is incredibly confusing.
I don't like the screen zooming out like that.
Oh, we each have to have a button.
We each have to have a button.
Jump on.
I got the left side.
Okay, I got this button.
Ow.
And then we have three more, three more.
That little hole, you see that little hole?
Just gotta climb it.
Yes!
Yay!
Where's the last one?
Oh, the last one's over there.
Not cracked.
I'm pushing the button.
And then...
Mint, this is your job to...
Okay.
To not die?
I mean...
I can always go back.
Ooh.
Go back on the button.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, that one.
I just went through.
Wait, was that me?
Did you just abandon us?
No, it's okay, guys.
Wait, which button is that?
You just come back when you remember about me, okay?
Is it this one?
I'll find you!
I got you.
Who would have...
Who could have done such a thing?
Wow.
You trapped me in the green world.
Okay.
Wait, anything but that.
I'm gross.
What do we do about live?
No, I'm over here.
Who's that that's lost and stuck?
Just, okay, here.
Just jump like this.
Just jump.
I'm scared.
I'm sorry.
Do you like the little projectile I made for you?
The analysis on how to jump?
Sorry.
You should be sorry.
We have like a laser pointer for our cat.
A laser pointer to guide her.
Yay!
Wow!
What the heck?
I'm gonna be so proud of all of you guys.
Alright, let's show you guys how much we have.
This is so easy.
Oh, never mind.
What the heck is this?
That's just what is right at the end.
We should just do the last level.
Guys, okay, let's see what it's like.
Yeah, let's just see what it's like.
Yeah.
That's not good, is it?
Yes, it is!
Just go right!
No!
Have a great life, everyone.
Well, maybe not everyone.
It's always yellow.
Yeah, it's always yellow.
Who is yellow?
Oh, my God!
You need to lock in by pressing D.
Hold down the right key one time.
Ah!
Wow, man!
What did I tell you?
How do we actually, like, ignore that?
I'm gonna get out.
Stop jumping over.
This is a pig issue.
We actually would have made that if it hadn't been for you, Donkey.
You were so close that time.
Did you just run over everybody?
No!
Ah!
Everyone just grabbed a wall.
Oh, my bad.
I went backwards.
Guys, if we can be level one...
If we can be this level, we can be all the other levels, guys.
That's so true!
I feel like the other level is the baddest for this.
Okay.
We have to stack to the side, guys.
We have to play the game.
Why aren't you moving?
I'm trying to.
Run!
We played farther than we ever have.
That was really far.
Five in a row, huh?
World record!
Oh, my God.
We're back, we're back, we're back!
Okay, go, go, go, go!
Dang it.
We're so close.
We figured it out, though.
Oh, oh, oh, my God.
Oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God!
We'll get overfilled.
There can't be any delay, guys.
There can't be any delay.
Three, two, one!
We have to get away!
We can't stop!
Yikes!
Literally, it can't stop!
Hey, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Oh, my God.
I'm the end!
I'm pretty sure this kind of torture was depicted in the Bible.
Just hold it down!
Dante's Inferno would be like...
Which circle of hell is this?
One must imagine Sisyphus on the other side.
One must imagine Sisyphus at Pico Park.
Okay, well, we can do this, I believe.
Why is it always both of us?
It's because some of you guys have to go to the right side.
So we need, like, four people on the far right.
And then the rest of us have to bridge the thing.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go, go, go, go!
Okay, nice, nice.
Is the gear come back?
Yeah, we're going.
We're gonna go.
Oh, it does, it does.
I got you, little guy.
Okay, my life is in your hands.
Cradle.
Guys, we made it.
Oh, my God, we did it!
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's two saws.
What are you doing, you fool?
We'll see what happens to her.
Okay, keep going forward.
Okay.
Okay, everything seems okay.
I don't see a saw.
I think we're good.
He said that.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Hey, hey, wait a second.
What Kentucky hat?
I can't...
No, I don't deal with that.
I'm not...
Come on, come on, come on.
We're playing as a team.
Come on, come on.
Jingle, jingle, jingle.
Hold your hand.
We have a buddy system.
We should get a buddy system right now.
Just in case.
What have I just stood here?
We need to know what's up ahead.
What lies ahead of us.
Oh, no!
Get ready to go!
No!
Okay, what I have to do is...
I think we have to stack up to somewhere.
Okay, so let me just get over here.
Yeah, let's just get ready.
Wait, how does it go back down?
Yeah, we can't go back down.
I think we have to stack here.
No, but...
Let's see if there's anything up there.
We have to run and get to the safe point.
No, wait.
It's not going to go down once we have the...
How do we get back down?
I don't think there's anything up there.
Okay, so there's nothing up there.
Let the elevator go down and then maybe...
What if that was something up there?
Okay, I'm sensing...
Can you jump into the elevator?
Maybe the stars will go at a different time or something.
Where's the door?
Is it back there?
Are we sure nothing's up there?
Where was the door?
Yeah, the door is at the very beginning.
Oh, it is?
Oh, it was!
Okay, we send one lone soldier.
One brave soul.
Alright, Green, you're closest.
You got this, bro guy.
Green is closest.
Alright, Green, you're closest.
And we'll inch across to see how much space we can get.
One brave soul.
One brave son.
You have to get over so we can see the key.
Oh, oh.
Oh, gosh.
We can't even seize it if we want to.
Okay, get ready to go down.
Oh, god!
Okay.
Ready?
Guys, guys, guys, guys!
Get out of the way!
Don't let them massacre us!
Don't
let them massacre us!
Did you see the door?
We found it!
I still don't really know how to do a thing.
You have to do it one at a time.
I need to go single file.
Single file, yeah.
It's literally single file, which is what I was trying to say.
You need to jump single file.
Oh, come on, Toki!
Into the grave.
Feels like we're in kindergarten and Lime's the teacher.
Nah.
Mama!
Oh, my god!
Please!
I don't piss myself.
That was almost impressive.
Alright, let's go.
Any day now!
Jump over you if you're too strong!
Alright, we got this.
Okay!
Alright, Toki, I'll take you.
Toki, your big head is in the way.
Okay, there we go.
Watch out, Toki!
I'm okay, I'm okay!
Everything is fine!
See?
All good, everyone.
Bye!
A single soldier.
Just me.
From this world.
Okay.
We should all make, like, a single line.
No one on top of each other's head.
Let's do a test run.
Like, imagine we have the key.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah!
Ready, set, go!
Okay.
You gotta jump.
You gotta do this.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
At the very bottom, too.
Wait, can you jump and then it goes down a little bit?
Is that?
Yeah!
Oh, if you keep jumping!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Good system!
Okay, we have the mechanics now.
Don't forget the other one also needs the first one for victory.
Can this squish someone?
Oh.
Why would you immediately sacrifice yourself to find out?
For science!
She just loves playing this game, guys.
Are you ready?
You ready?
Go, go, go, go, go!
Here we go!
Alright.
Oh, I can't.
Oh!
Keep going!
Bring the key higher up or we'll be fucked over by the uh, the thing.
Yep, still there.
Oh, god.
The key won't move.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, you can pass it!
Yeah, you can pass it.
Okay, you're passing it to you.
Okay, I'll pass it to you.
How do you give it to somebody?
Okay, I guess not.
Okay, we'll go.
We gotta be patient.
Yeah, be patient.
The person ahead has to have the key!
Who has the key?
I've got the key!
Alright, go.
No, you go.
You have the key.
And we decide now.
You have the key and I'm the key.
And who's home?
Okay.
I'm gonna wait for the thing.
I'm scared.
Go!
I'll get out of the way.
Alright.
Three, two, one, go!
Woohoo!
Yay!
Okay.
I'm too scared.
Careful.
Don't panic.
Just gotta be patient.
Careful Spongebob.
Careful Squidward!
Careful Spongebob!
I'm scared.
I don't wanna go.
Please, we don't wanna do this again.
I wanna master this level.
Let's do it one more time.
Let's get a speedrun, guys.
Yeah, we could be faster for sure.
Yeah, we could really honestly be faster.
We could actually be on speedrun.com, guys.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Well, your wish came true, it seems.
I'll do it.
There's actually no way.
We were basically done.
I want to run back.
I will jump over your head.
One more time, she says.
Just one more time.
I can't get over there.
Oh my god.
Come on, just go, please.
I think we've learned from this that we would all be the first to die.
Hey, hey, hey.
What are you doing?
Oh man.
What are we talking about?
Okay, everything is fine.
We'll just leave room down there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Try again.
I don't want to try again.
Wait, so who's white?
Oh my god, it was Amelie.
Alright.
We got this.
It's okay.
We'll get the world record now.
We'll get the world record.
That's a funny one.
You guys can actually go up more than one by one.
Yeah.
This is kind of fast.
I'm locked in, guys.
Alright.
Okay, there we go.
Let's go.
Single file line, remember guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm sorry.
Go, go, go.
I had to wait.
I had to wait to see it.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
Go, go, go.
I didn't have to wait.
I forgot I could just move.
You have to jump up and down to make it go down fast.
Alright.
Nice, I'm ahead.
It's a miracle we got all the people just like massacred immediately there.
We only got massacred about two seconds later.
How does she do that?
It's like wall hacking.
What is this?
How do you do it so fast?
It's the only way we can get this.
It doesn't matter.
It ain't done already.
I'm stuck.
I'm not letting you jump past me.
We're so back.
That was good.
It was good.
This is the run, guys.
Okay, I'll walk over so you guys can go down.
Oh, never mind.
Sorry.
That's a good plan.
Okay, sorry.
Just, uh, you know.
You'll make it.
You just gotta get there.
Just get up here, guys.
Can't be that bad.
You know what you're saying, right?
Nightmare, nightmare.
We can do this.
It's always you and me, Ren.
Stop pushing me.
I'm not pushing you.
I'm not touching you.
You're touching my aura.
Here we go.
Be ready.
Okay, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Okay, okay.
Two can be at the same time.
You have to jump.
And when you get, if it starts moving up, you jump.
And then it'll go back down even faster.
Guys, can you try not dying?
I know, but there are people all the way with me.
How do you do that?
Every time you do that, we die.
No, it's not true.
It's true.
Oh, Jesus.
What?
How?
What happened?
Stop.
Sorry.
It starts so fast.
Ever since the gray incident, it's never been the same.
Our motivation is gone.
Salvation.
I'm gray, like my will to live.
Okay, here we go.
The jumping will not work if there's tons of you on the platform, because you would all have to jump at exactly the same place.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we got it right the first time.
What happened to us?
I happened.
Which last time?
And a greed happened.
We're becoming masters of this level.
It's fine.
That's not something to be proud of.
We're going to be so good for the next one, though.
We're going to be so good at Chapter 2.
If we beat Chapter 15 with like zero knowledge, we got this.
Okay.
Someone do an example just to make sure we know what to do at this point.
Alright, guys.
Okay, let's practice, guys.
Okay, let's practice.
Here we go.
Your turn.
One at a time.
Okay.
You just do that.
Lime would have been dead.
I feel like we have to have a drill sergeant in Peacock Park.
Go, go, go, go.
Children, this is a fire drill.
Okay?
Imagine if there's a fire.
Alright.
Okay.
This is the run.
Yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go.
Guys, guys.
One at a time.
Okay.
Get the key close.
The first person has to unlock the door.
Guys, guys, guys, please.
There's a green goblin on my head.
Okay.
Alright, Bao.
It's all up to you.
You're unlocking.
Alright.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay.
Alright, Min.
It's up to you.
I'm waiting for it.
Okay.
Don't answer the call of the void.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, we can do it.
We're back.
I'm scared.
I don't think we should risk death.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait till it goes back.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I'll go first.
Okay.
Slow and steady.
Amelie, you go next.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, now we should be good.
Now we should be good.
Okay, let's have that thing go back up and down.
Please.
No.
Oh my god.
Nice, okay.
Nice.
No way you lose these.
Let's go.
We are finally on the scoreboard.
This is so good.
I held my breath and I feel lightheaded.
How do we already pull it from the way through?
How do I get up?
Don't you go back there.
Oh, come on.
Let's learn the game.
Let's learn the game, guys.
Now?
Now, why were we on level 15?
Oh no, what is this?
The worm!
Just don't die.
Okay, you guys.
Jump over it.
We can jump over it.
Oh, you can stand on it, I think.
You can stand on it.
I say it's the velocity that gets you.
Oh, who died?
My bad.
Apologies.
Okay, the order changes every time.
Who was pushing me?
I wasn't even pressing my keys.
What?
The order changes every time, guys.
Okay.
I can't jump if you're on my head.
Stop it.
Something about a chungus butt.
Okay, that is all right.
No, it's not good.
I'm coming back.
Let's try not to get tangled.
Okay.
We have to stack.
Doki, swap with me.
I see.
What if you fall?
Will you drag us all with us?
Yes.
I think so.
We need you to get out.
I can't move.
Actually, it's not letting me.
There we go.
Don't push me off the edge.
Mr. Purple, can you...
I'm moonwalking.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, sorry.
Okay.
And then...
Jump over and then...
Wait.
Drag and drag and drag.
Hey.
Where am I supposed to be?
I'm confused.
Let me go.
It's a tug-of-war.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Checkpoint.
Jump over.
And then we'll just lower you down.
Okay.
What order are we in?
We should untangle real quick.
I am here.
I can't tell at all.
I think... Oh, there.
Okay, we're good.
How does this one person...
Oh, we have to stack maybe again?
I think that's just a jump.
I think you jump.
Why would they do that if it weren't for the level design?
Maybe.
Oh, I got it.
Okay, we got it.
We got it.
Okay, let's try it again.
Oh, no.
We have to be untangled.
This is so romantic.
What if...
What if two or three of us jump at the same time and get weight on the other side?
Two of you guys jump.
Let me free.
Yeah.
One direction and we really did it without thinking.
Who's next to me?
Oh, my God.
How did you guys get tangled like that?
Wait, what the heck?
I don't know actually.
Oh, we're making a star.
Wait, I'm supposed to be over here.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I'm supposed to be over here.
Okay.
You are still tangled.
There's some double looping going on on that rope.
I'm pretty sure.
Really?
Where?
Okay.
All yours.
I think you guys have to jump off of my head for this.
Eight, four, and six have to jump together.
Yeah.
We should get closer so that they don't get pulled back.
Oh, my God.
I love the cascade effect.
We did it.
We need to pull these cats up.
Pull them up.
Okay.
Now what?
Untangle.
All right.
How come it's always the tail end that's tangled up like that?
How come?
I don't know.
What are you guys doing?
We're fine over here.
Yeah, we're here.
It's not me, man.
Why are you guys tangling up?
Guys, why are you guys tangling up?
It's because I have to be put down.
Pink and orange.
Okay, fine.
If you're so perfect over here then, why don't you be a little bit more tangled?
Okay?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You tell them.
Yeah.
Let's swap.
Let's swap places.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It'll be so tangled that we can't fall.
We can do this.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just like the rubber bands.
Oh!
Do we launch somebody?
No, no, no.
Trust, trust.
Tangle and jump over together.
As a whole ball of yarn.
We should just jump so we can be untangled.
I cannot jump with Dari on my head.
If we jump, we lose our keys.
Oh!
Okay, alright.
Let's just get these guys out here first.
Okay, we're just gonna jump.
We're just gonna...
Alright, let's just do a jump.
Let's just jump.
It's not gonna work.
We just need to make a little staircase.
What is this?
If we make a staircase and then we have someone fall into the gap.
Yes, I have a suggestion.
Without tangling, we do need to make a staircase and have someone on the end then jump off.
Okay.
Not like that.
Hold again.
That wasn't the full sentence.
I got pushed, guys.
Somebody pushed me.
That can't be possible.
This way, we need to have, like, in reverse order, Okay, so someone needs to be on Doki that is like...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Someone needs to be under Doki.
Yeah, purple under Doki.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, like that.
But I need to go to the other side.
Like that, okay.
So if you tell me to get to the edge and then I jump, that will hopefully be enough.
Okay.
Oh!
My goodness gracious.
Okay, everyone just get in so they can fall.
Where's my vacuum?
The vacuum figured it out!
The
vacuum figured it out, guys.
Yay!
Big brain!
Oh, no.
At least we can't die here.
Yeah, we just gotta pull each other out.
Yeah, we just gotta do it.
We just need a couple of us to pull the others off.
The people on the bottom of the stack need to walk off at the same time.
Alright.
So we need to all stack into a big group.
Like a huge group.
We just become a conglomeration and then we need to, like, walk off at the same time.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Um...
Okay, blue and red.
You walk off and I can jump.
Oh, okay.
We need to just keep going.
Just you and me.
I'm gonna go too.
I shouldn't have had those tacos.
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay, guys, guys.
We don't have to move, guys.
Just stay still.
Everybody stay still.
I need you to touch the wall.
I'm touching the wall.
I'm making out with the wall.
And then...
Okay, okay.
No, no, no.
Rin, stay on top.
I don't think Doki can.
No, Snuffy has to move.
And then I can jump.
And then we all move.
Oh my gosh.
I literally got carried this whole time.
Yay.
Thank you so much for...
Yippee!
Don't touch me!
No!
Doki!
Doki, you're gonna die!
Okay.
Nobody touch anyone!
Oh, my...
We were basically dead.
Okay, we gotta keep going.
We have one HP!
Oh, that was Doki!
This is all Doki!
I'm okay!
You have so much HP!
Someone get on here, but don't touch me!
I'm not touching you.
Six feet, guys!
Guys, I don't wanna...
Guys, please.
Me!
There's ice up there!
It's ice!
Oh, it's ice!
Doki, don't touch me!
Don't touch me, Doki!
I'm not touching you!
Yes, you are!
Stop!
I just wanted to touch you, Doki!
I just bricked you!
No, don't touch me, though.
Oh, my God!
Stop!
We're too close!
It's hot enough!
Go!
It's ice!
Sorry!
Okay.
I'm sorry!
I'm trying to go back for you!
Okay, you first!
What does this do?
Oh!
Scoot!
Scoot along a bit!
Wait, how will you...
Well, I need you to scoot so I can go...
No, I need you to...
Actually, this works!
This works!
No!
Nobody touch me!
Don't touch!
Where?
Sorry!
Oh!
Hey, we didn't touch, though!
I think you did because...
Oh!
There we go!
Don't touch me!
Try not to jump off early if you're on the right because you leave your friend behind.
There we go.
Oh!
The slip and slide there!
Uh!
Guys, just...
Scoot!
Just a little jump!
Okay?
There we go!
Hold on!
We jump at the same time!
Oh!
Sorry!
Y'all got a button!
I know what those words mean.
Three... Two... One...
Jump!
Oh!
Ouch!
Nice!
Everything is fun!
We each get a button, I guess?
Yeah, I think so.
Gentle!
Stop!
I'm looking at you!
I know!
Yay!
Let's go!
Okay.
Oh my god!
She looks so pretty!
I'm doing my part.
Don't touch me!
I'm not even pressing anything at this point.
Oh my god!
Oh!
It doesn't kill you!
That's so good!
Ouch!
Doki!
Hahaha!
Aim!
There you go!
Hmm... Hmm...
Hmm...
Hahaha!
That's just the way!
Wait!
I twirled!
Oh my god!
Yippee!
Yay!
I'm sweating!
Me too!
I'm taking off my hoodie.
Holy!
My palms are moist!
Oh no!
Not what I want to hear in this game.
Oh, it's this again.
We're already tangled.
It's been three seconds.
Oh, we can touch again!
We are mostly untangled, except for Mint and Doki.
I'm not tangled!
I'm exactly where I was!
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Snuffy, is this you?
Snuffy, am I touching you right now?
The pink one.
Oh, you're even more pink!
Oh!
Wait, who am I touching?
That's Rin.
Oh, hi Rin!
Hi Rin!
Okay, and then I'm up here.
Good.
You gotta jump with us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just don't...
Oh, sorry!
Hahaha!
Stop it!
Alright, the two of us...
Okay...
Alright, back to the line.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay, alright.
I went a little too... I was a little too eager.
I'm sorry.
There we go.
Okay.
Yeah.
Don't go down the hole.
I'm sorry.
Don't fall down the hole.
Don't fall down.
Just make the jump.
If you don't make it, we all die.
Did you not get it?
Backwards.
I don't know what to do.
Three of us have to jump lower.
I think a few of us have to jump lower.
There we go.
Guys.
What the fuck am I looking at here?
Alright.
I think we gotta untangle first.
Yup, yup, yup, yup.
I am supposed to be...
So, yellow, red, green...
Aren't I at the end?
Are we at the end?
We were almost untangled.
We were almost... okay.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
Okay.
Try again.
Alright.
This is it.
One more time.
Gray, orange, and green should all go?
Yeah.
Green can go, but not gray.
Wait.
Three, two, one.
Who's going?
Go.
Oh!
Why did we all go?
Why?
That was so...
That was so close.
Why did we all go?
We got that.
I think everyone does need to be going, yeah.
Everyone.
Okay.
No, no.
I don't think everybody.
I think it has to be like the top four walk off.
There's enough weight on the other side.
It's definitely more than one person.
I think we need three people to pull the rest of us across.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, I'm losing my fucking mind at this music right now.
Normally,
so I kind of like it.
I'm at peace.
Okay, somebody is not where they're supposed to be.
I should be in the back.
Or the front, I guess.
The two M's are at the same end.
Alright.
Okay, now this is a lot more tangled.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
There we go, there we go.
Okay, purple, then red, then yellow.
Now we climb.
I cannot allow you in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Climber.
Okay, I'm as far as I can go.
Tippy pixel tip.
Look at how much room you have.
Holy shit.
You can't miss.
Okay, so it's probably like...
Okay, so it's right there.
Just walk.
Okay.
Right.
Ahhh!
No!
How did that happen?
What?
We all had to keep walking forward.
I'm gonna be sick.
What?
What's going on?
Oh, Christ.
Yeah, you have to keep pulling right.
Somebody's sand was off the keyboard.
We all gotta pull our parts.
Okay, stack, stack, stack!
Okay.
Stack, stack, stack, stack.
Holy shit.
I can't, I can't.
Oh, there we go, there we go.
Just keep walking.
Okay, cool.
Okay.
We can't lose this.
Just hold D.
Don't stop.
Ahhh!
That's been a miscommunication.
We're so done!
Yeah!
I'm almost there!
Okay.
In order, I guess.
In order, in order.
Okay, we figured it out.
Wait, I'm behind you.
Okay, Juniper at the end.
Alright, here we go.
Nice!
Oh!
Wait, we need this, we need this!
Wait, it has to be like this.
Yeah, it has to be like this.
Don't jump!
Go back, go back, go back, go back.
Go back, go back, go back.
Okay.
Okay, only one person needs to...
Oh, look, I can swing you!
Oh, that's so gross.
Oh my god.
You just jump.
I am trying to jump but the weight is fucking me up.
Are you sure it shouldn't be the person on the end?
Oh, Rin.
Help me.
I cannot jump.
One has to be tangled.
Oh, Jessica.
No, I think it's just the dangle, right?
And then the next person goes.
Yeah, I think there's someone at the end, maybe.
Because then we can easily pull them up.
I feel like there should be someone in the middle, no?
Because I cannot see...
What's the puzzle?
I didn't see it.
There's a button at the dangle.
No, there's the key in the middle.
I don't know if you have to hit the buttons or what.
Or avoid them.
Oh, frick.
That's gross.
I kind of hate that.
We probably got boxed in one.
For a reason.
I think the buttons are bad news.
Maybe it's like as many people as possible jump across and then one goes down and you have to counterbalance it between the two.
Let's try.
Okay, pull me up.
Thank you, man.
Don't go too far.
We're tangled up, but we did it.
Alright, now we jump across.
Let's just get maybe four of us.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Why do I go too far?
Keep jumping.
Jump like this.
Oh, sorry.
Now we walk across.
And then we jump.
Okay.
If we...
Go a little bit.
Oh, and then we can drag.
Yeah, okay.
Juniper, don't jump.
Just fall.
Sorry, I'm gonna dangle, bros.
I'm going down.
Dangle, dangle, dangle.
I told you the buttons were bad news!
I said the buttons were bad news!
The buttons are a trick!
I told you!
I think we're right.
We do need to be super tangled so that the line is shorter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dangle her!
Emily, you go down.
We gotta pull up.
Three more apart.
Wait, jump on top of someone, right?
So I'm connected to one and two.
One and two seem to be farther apart.
The farther apart you are, the shorter the line.
Okay, orange and yellow.
No, no!
Okay, I can't jump!
I can't jump!
It's so noisy!
Okay.
Keep walking.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Alright, now come together.
Pull up the baby.
Okay.
Okay, itch, itch.
Okay, there we go.
Alright,
nice.
Oh my goodness.
We've done the impossible.
Oh my god, we actually did it.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
Am I the only one tall enough to ride the ride?
You just got carried the whole time.
Get in the backpack.
Isn't that so fun?
Amelie, can you talk for me?
I need to adjust your volume.
I couldn't even register what was happening.
Test me.
One, two, three, test me.
That's better, thank you.
I think I need to change Juniper, too.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, Sorgi.
Oh, I have to push the box?
Yeah, yeah, because you're orange.
Hey, don't touch me.
Sorry, I was clicking back in on your adjusting discord.
I think we start over, we start over.
No, no, no.
Okay.
I know us.
We need the full help.
Just the box.
Alright, this time it's Amelie touches the box.
Okay.
I'm not even moving.
Like, how are you guys hitting me?
Oh, it's your box.
Okay, you can get on the bus and we'll jump over you.
Amelie, it's your box.
It's your box.
It's the Amelie box.
Yeah, it's the Amelie box.
We have to jump over her.
Yeah, jump over.
Push, push.
She's collecting the trash.
I'm sorry, I shocked you.
Don't beat the trash man.
What the?
How did that even happen?
She's rubbing her toes on her head.
I know.
Whacking me on my scalp.
I only have a few brain cells.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait.
Oh, it's a wall that pushes us back.
Oh, no.
Evil wall.
There's a hole, there's a hole.
Go, go, go.
Okay.
Oh, it's time, time, Dicey.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, so we wait, so we wait.
Yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go, go.
I think we're gonna die.
Guys, we have one HP left, guys.
Jump up.
You can.
Can you move forward?
Keep moving, guys, keep moving.
Keep moving, keep moving.
We would've died anyway.
Okay, my turn.
Okay.
Alright, it's Doki's box.
It's your box now.
Jump over my head.
Oh, okay.
How do we keep him?
You guys gotta jump over me, guys.
My bad, I forgot how this works.
My box.
Oh, shit, my bad.
My bad, my bad.
I am not moving, so you touch me.
It's your fault.
I'm not moving.
There's plenty of space.
No, there's not.
You need to move forward.
There's plenty of space.
Be careful, friends.
Oh, no.
Hey, guys.
Guys, I need you guys.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, just run forward, just run forward.
Just go.
Just go, there's nothing down there.
What do you mean there's nothing down there?
Just go, Doki, go.
What?
Again?
Look at me, I'm like in the water right now.
We're gonna be okay, eventually.
Come on.
There's plenty of room, Doki, just go for it.
There's plenty of room.
I will.
No, we only have three hits left.
No!
How so?
I thought I could make the shot.
Everyone, I need the room for Jesus.
Wait, how do we get the key?
How do we?
You gotta make a jump, I think.
Oh.
Okay, not like that.
Oh, I didn't realize it was me at the end.
You need room for Jesus.
I think it was one of us.
We need to save one HP, so we can stack and get the key.
I think so, yeah.
Yeah, I agree.
Brilliant, brilliant.
In the ideal scenario, we save all of the HP.
No, the perfect world is asking too much for us.
Alright, Amelie, your turn.
Amelie.
Rude!
Alright.
Oh!
Doki!
I didn't move!
Yay!
Alright, go, go, go!
Nice.
My turn.
See, I made it.
I'm waiting for it.
I got nervous.
It's okay.
Alright, Snuffy, you go up.
You push up.
You have to kiss the wall.
We're getting performance anxiety in people park.
Oh!
Go, go, go!
You can make the jump.
It's okay, it's okay.
Relax, relax.
Yeah, there you go.
There's space.
There's room.
There's a lot of room, guys.
Oh, sorry.
Please go forward.
Can I?
It's okay.
The wall won't hurt you.
Yeah, you can touch the wall.
You and me.
It's hurting my mind.
You gotta go up.
A fan?
What does this mean?
What's gonna happen to me?
What's gonna happen to that?
Oh, it's just gonna push us up.
Oh, but we have to be careful not to hit ourselves.
Wait, what are we?
Okay, I'm coming.
We all know how to count, right guys?
We all know how to count.
Three...
Wait, it's gonna go down into the water, right?
What are we gonna do?
Okay, okay.
Just keep shimmying.
Just keep.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're fine.
We can do this.
Oh.
That's not too soon.
Who said we can do this?
We can do this.
Yeah.
Guys, we beat level 15.
We can beat level 2.
We got this.
Okay.
There we go.
Make way.
Ouch.
Okay.
Make way.
Nice.
Alright.
Make way.
Okay.
I will raid your box.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I don't think she trusts us on making the jump.
I don't think so.
I don't think she trusts us in parkour.
Is the thing gonna...
Is the thing going?
It's kind of like...
There it is.
Okay.
I'll grab the key so don't come through.
I'm staying completely still.
Wait.
Wait there.
Oh, okay.
I'll wait there.
I'll wait here.
Wait.
Yeah.
Do not continue, friends.
Do not continue.
I got slapped in the face by the wall.
Almost pushing.
Someone else has got to get the key.
Good luck.
Okay.
I'm not believing you.
I can't get it.
I can't reach the wall anymore.
I'm not touching you.
She's touching me.
You guys have to go forward.
Guys.
I don't know.
Three people at once is a good idea.
Why are you coming back off?
I didn't think that was a good idea.
Yes, Ripper.
What is happening over there?
Figure it out.
Alright.
I'm gonna get smushed.
She's touching me, man.
Purple needs to move forward.
Yes.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm moving in 17 different directions at once.
I learned how to park before.
Okay.
We're fine.
I'm not touching you.
Okay.
One at a time.
Now jump.
Jump.
Go fast.
I'm not trying to make you nervous.
What was that?
One last time.
Run.
We need to do that faster.
We have to jump off the thingy.
Don't touch me.
Nobody move.
They're so stupid.
Okay.
Bow.
Bow is your boss.
Oh, sorry.
Please.
We had two years to practice.
That's so fun.
Ow.
Sorry.
That meant my broken bones.
This is not the run, bros.
Yeah.
Let's just die.
We're done.
Nobody move.
I'm dead.
It was like five people in a row.
Okay.
This is it.
Chungus.
Chungus head.
I love your Chungus head.
I'm moving.
Keep moving a little bit.
That was personal, I think.
Alright.
This is fine.
That's for dying on the 15th.
Come here.
Push.
We'll never forget.
Never forget.
We know what you did.
Five more times.
Okay.
I'm going.
We're going together.
Bow, I believe in you.
Okay.
Ready?
Bow, I believe in you.
I did it.
Go, go.
Big.
Oh, sorry.
I couldn't go forward.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Alright.
We have enough room for all three of you guys technically.
Technically.
All we gotta do is move forward.
Alright, alright, alright.
Are we all ready?
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
We got it now.
Okay.
Go.
Just file to the end and scoot left.
Everyone, scoot left.
Okay.
Scoot.
Please.
Okay.
Now we get off.
We just gotta...
Go.
Just get inside.
Okay.
Yay.
Oh, lord.
I can feel the tension in my brain.
I need meditation after this.
We're gonna be such great friends after this game.
Formation.
We're still gonna be friends, you think?
What is this?
Is this red light, green light?
I'm gonna piss.
Someone's gonna piss.
This isn't the epilepsy level, is it?
Someone has to piss.
Okay, go use the bathroom.
Go.
Figure this out while you're gone.
It's just red light, green light.
It's Metal Gear, actually.
I don't know who it was.
I think it was Juniper.
It wasn't me.
I am quiet.
I think it was Emily, then.
Okay, so light hurts, by the way.
Yeah.
That's just how it is.
As a gamer.
Okay, so...
There's only like enough space.
Unless we stack.
We could stack, yeah.
Yeah, I have my...
Go here!
Yeah, but we can't stack too high.
Because there's still a little light.
Oh my goodness.
Sorry, I moved.
Wait, what if we all just stack?
Oh, that's true!
No, I think we'll get the light.
See, it gets small.
I see.
I think it's groups of three, maybe.
Or four.
Get behind me!
Wait.
I for-gore.
For-gore?
Can we do four?
Or can we only do three?
I think we can do four.
We definitely can.
We have space for four.
Okay, it has to be just here.
I have brain damage.
I mean, after that last level.
Everyone on top of your head.
Yeah.
Wait, no.
I played this game right now.
This is so funny.
Oh, it's me.
It's fine.
She can solo this, I believe.
Actually, no.
She cannot solo this.
Okay, I'm back.
Okay.
She can't solo it.
The little click is so nice.
We can get five.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
I bet we could make a perfect diamond pyramid.
Yeah.
Let's show her beautiful skills.
Okay.
It's not working.
Do we have enough room to make a perfect diamond pyramid?
Yeah, we can.
There we go.
It's beautiful.
Wow.
This is not a time.
We can stack two people on top of us, too.
Maybe purple jump on top, too.
Purple jump up.
How does pink get up?
Red jump up.
Oh, sorry.
And then we must realign.
How does snuffy get up?
I think maybe green makes a little room.
I can move a little bit.
See if red can get on top of bow.
Oh.
Oh, guys.
We're getting closer.
Okay.
Let's not assemble that.
Let's just do five.
Let's just do five with me.
We can't get too fancy.
Come over here.
Okay.
I want snuffy's pyramid to happen, though.
Yeah, I'm kind of curious.
Wait.
Who's going to be at the bottom?
Should we go bow at the bottom?
Yes.
It can be this tall.
This is as tall as it can be.
Okay.
It needs to be...
It can't be any bigger than two at the bottom.
I'm pretty sure...
Okay.
Now you can stack up.
Why did you lose, buddy?
Why did you lose?
We just need two different stacks.
Please.
We're trying to be fancy.
But we wanted to be a beautiful pyramid.
You pyramid haters.
We're already beautiful.
My bad.
Pyramids aren't always worth it.
That's a recent school of pyramid scheme.
Here you go.
I get it.
All right.
Look at that.
Now we're a boring line.
We can't have nice things, guys.
I love boring lines.
You're beautiful and efficient.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Two stacks before.
I still trust Bao despite her failure.
My failure?
Oh, Jesus.
So what happened was...
Ended so fast.
No, trust me.
I'm a professional.
I still trust Bao.
We're swapping bottoms.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
I'll catch up.
Don't worry.
He'll catch up.
But will that mean I can catch up?
I'm topping.
I'm popping.
I trust Bao.
I'm on Bao.
Give Bao a gun.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go.
I would not give Bao a gun.
Wait.
Missing quick.
Missing quick?
You've lost it.
Maybe I trust Rin more.
I don't know.
That's a dangerous statement.
You bitch.
And that's what happens when you don't fully trust the one at the bottom.
Maybe we should swap the bottom.
I have been the one giving you my face.
Stop fighting.
All right.
Here we go.
Okay.
All right.
I think it has to be a line.
It's on the other side of the level.
It's got to be a line or it's too dangerous.
Okay.
Trust.
I was throwing but now I'm going to lock in for real.
I trust Bao.
Let's realign this to be a perfect line.
Yeah.
I trust Bao.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
You're getting awfully close there, Bao.
You're getting awfully close there.
Get up.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Holy shit.
I don't like it.
What about this down area?
How the fuck does this work?
Checkpoint.
Thank God.
They knew deep down at this level.
Oh, nice.
I think we have to go back.
We have to do the trust run.
More people have got to get people over there.
Okay.
It's fine.
Hold on.
You got to run.
I'm sprinting.
You have trapped me on the platform.
Okay.
I'm good.
We can stack this up.
We can stack this up technically.
I don't trust you, Doki.
Okay.
See.
I told you.
I told you we can stack this up.
I can't go downstairs.
Let's try.
Thank God almighty for the checkpoint.
More than we needed it.
We're going again.
That was so funny.
We have to move the camera over, I think.
Yeah.
Someone has to move the camera over.
I'll move the camera.
Okay.
Can I?
No.
The camera.
Yeah.
I need more people to come in.
Maybe more people down here.
Okay.
Everyone get on top of me.
We just got to stack all the way up.
There's no light that's going to hurt us.
Trust me.
All you have to do is get on top of me.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know about it.
Two stacks of four.
No way we lose these.
Keep stacking.
Okay.
Green move a little bit forward.
Yup.
There we go.
And then purple move forward.
Okay.
Wait.
Why?
We're ready.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Next one.
Purple move forward a little.
Go.
Wait.
It's too late.
As soon as it disappears.
Yeah.
Okay.
Go.
What?
I hate no way.
Trust me.
Hand me the gun.
Put it in my hand.
Judge, jury, and executioner.
That was so evil.
We just hug the left wall after we get over.
Yeah.
Just hug the left wall.
We're going to fall and then not move.
Yeah.
After this one.
And...
Go!
We're just going to fall and not move.
Left.
Okay.
Now go.
Go.
No.
Let's go.
Wait.
Easy game.
Easy.
It's so easy.
What the fuck?
They did that so hard.
Every man for themselves.
You can't.
You guys all just ran.
What is this?
Don't be on it.
This is going to go great, I think.
Yeah.
I think there's going to be an obstacle over there.
We're sailing.
Line.
Thank you.
Ohh.
Watch out.
Oooo.
First try baby.
We're gaming.
We're gaming now.
So big it didn't touch her.
We have to sass.
Okay.
But we're getting there.
Yeah.
That was pretty good.
Okay.
Line.
That was our first one too.
Does anyone else...
Look at the wrong color.
Part the middle!
Okay.
Now to the left.
Left!
To the left!
Oh wait, we have to stay in the middle.
Yeah, yeah.
When it starts going down.
Okay, so let's stack in the middle.
Line!
I'm thinking you guys are specifically yelling at me.
And calling me out.
What?
What's the middle?
We're yelling at everybody.
Now we have to stack in the middle.
Stack in the middle!
There we go.
Oh my god.
Our simulation will come next.
That's it?
Oh my god.
Yay!
You better hurry up!
When you get the key and you put it...
You better do a flip!
Okay.
It's time to put the key in the hole.
I'm playing hot potato with the key.
I feel like the hardest part was getting that key in the hole.
Wait, was that really timed chat?
Or am I crazy?
No, they were fucking with us.
Oh no!
I've got utility.
What's the skill?
Okay.
Bow you don't suck, bow you don't suck!
Oh, okay.
Oh god, what is this?
Whoa!
Wait, this is so cool!
Three, two...
What's happening here?
What is this?
Oh!
What the?
How are you supposed to do this?
We have to be in line.
Wow!
So everybody is going to suck in the line.
Just jump, just jump.
Anyone plays suck, you suck.
No, you suck.
I suck, you suck.
Each of us holds square, guys.
Oh, sorry.
Each of us holds...
Here we go!
You're supposed to wait for us.
Yay!
We have to be all sucked up.
Suck.
My mind hurts.
This one blows my mind.
I don't even know what this is.
Okay, so...
Bow gonna suck.
I suck.
We all suck together.
And then Bow pushes us forward.
Huh?
So we're all gripped up.
And then she pushes...
What?
Yeah, we're all gripped up.
Okay, we lost our platforms.
Alright, now...
Do I have to be on the end?
Because I don't know how to join the suck.
No, no, no.
You all go face right side.
You all face right.
And then I hold you guys.
Yeah, yeah.
And then we all hug each other like...
Like we're friends.
What?
And then there you go.
Now you go into the fucking void.
But how does that help us avoid the wall?
Wait, how is that gonna help?
Yeah, how do we avoid the wall?
Oh my god.
You guys are sucking in mid-air.
I love it.
I love it too.
Are we creating a perpetual motion machine?
I don't understand.
Physics kneels before Pico Park 2.
Okay.
Do you have like a zigzag pattern?
No, no, no.
So we leave 24-7 suck?
In front of the car.
If we do need to be in a line...
Why wouldn't it work?
The person on the end of the line needs to be on the far right hand side of the platform.
So when the platform goes up, they don't collide with the block.
So they have to hold everybody else off the platform while standing on the very end of the platform by themselves.
I'm pretty sure.
That's how you suck.
Yeah, we all need to suck real hard.
We all face the same direction, guys, while you're sucking.
Face the same direction, everybody.
Me as well?
The end as well?
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, you all face and then you push us out.
You push us up.
The rest of us do not move.
Don't stop sucking.
I have not stopped sucking yet.
I'm literally crying.
I see the mission.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, stop this.
Oh, I stayed alive.
I see the mission.
I see it.
I see it now.
We gotta reverse the suck now.
Alright.
Okay.
I don't wanna be on the end.
Please, please.
Could you let me go for a second?
You guys ready?
Do not move, guys.
Do not move, everybody.
Okay.
We're sucking.
Alright, and then we turn around.
Once we're here?
Yeah.
Okay, turn.
You guys all turn around.
I got this.
Here we go.
Woo!
Oh no!
What the...
I didn't know I had to be on the end like that!
Okay, I got you guys.
Wait, which way is it?
Oh wait, I'll be on this side.
Okay, here we go.
Push, push, push up so we can connect.
Alright.
Here we go.
No one let go.
No one move.
I'll never let you go.
You're trolling.
I'm trying to let you go.
Yeah!
Stop sucking!
Okay, go, go.
You gotta really edge back here, okay?
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Big, big, huge...
We are so back.
We made it.
Yay!
Oh my god, I saw what we did.
Yippee!
Yay!
We sucked the victory!
My brain.
We sucked so hard.
I can feel the pressure on my brain.
Me too.
I feel like my brain just got sucked.
Wait, remember what?
Remember?
Why is there a timer?
Just remember your own spot!
Okay, remember the colors, maybe?
What am I remembering?
I already forgot!
Huh?
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
Wait, I was here.
I was down here.
I was literally just doing this.
Okay, now we're kissing.
We are kissing.
Oh my god.
It's only like...
13, 12...
Am I here?
I think I'm here.
Wait, what?
You have to remove the blocks.
You have to remove the blocks as well.
Oh, we have to remove the blocks.
How close are we?
Oh.
Guys, I don't see it.
Okay, I got it.
We are supposed to have every single one of our mistakes.
Brilliant.
I like how it...
Wow.
You were so fucking loud.
I was right!
Remember your squares.
I didn't.
Okay, I know what I'm doing.
It's gonna be great.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Purple's gotta push their square all the way downstairs.
I have a box.
I got this.
I'm pretty sure I do nothing.
Oh, wait, how do I...
Oh, wait.
No, no.
Wait, box, come back!
Box, wait!
My box!
Don't drop my box!
No, my box!
Wait, where was my box?
Wait, I don't remember, actually.
I don't know why I did it.
Can we redo?
Huge.
She was begging you, and you still did it.
Oh, I was right!
Oh, I was spacing the wrong way.
Yay!
I like how the game's like...
Oh, what?
I have to face the right direction?
Huh?
I hate it here!
Look!
My box!
My poor box!
Tester memory.
No, I have to keep the box down.
Okay.
Me.
I just need to be next to Red.
I need to chill out with Doki, and everything is going to be okay.
Wait, I thought I was blue for some reason.
I've already messed up.
Oh God.
I messed it all up, Rose.
I don't know what to do.
I am successful, I am flourishing.
What do you mean you don't know what to do?
I thought I was blue for some reason.
I was looking at bow, I was voicing on the map for no reason.
You fool!
I'll push the box a little bit to the right.
She can't!
She's blue!
Oh my gosh.
Amelie's just like kissing that box.
Where's Juniper?
I was just cussing!
I was looking at the wrong person!
I'm sorry you threw.
I threw, bros.
I threw.
We were so close!
That's all me, baby.
Oh, okay.
Mine's easy.
Easy peasy.
I'm here and my box is slightly here.
I love this for me.
Okay.
I'm here.
This one's good.
Okay, I'm here.
Me and Lime got it so easy.
Easiest assignment ever.
Yeah, good luck everybody else.
Yeah, I get to stay here.
It's your fault.
It's your boss.
What the fuck is this box doing over here?
Get this box out of my face.
Hey, don't push us.
Okay, I'm done.
Wait, I'm so close!
Wait, please!
Oh my god!
Wait, that might be good.
We were so close.
Oh my god, so close.
Oh my god.
This is so difficult.
Oh man.
I don't have to do any work.
That's nice.
I like this one.
Wait, did I just spawn in the right place?
Yeah, you did.
I'm done.
I don't know about you guys.
Okay, this is where I am.
Alright.
No, no, no!
Wait, my box!
Why did you take it?
It was right where...
Get off of me!
Okay.
Wait, did you...
I'm sorry!
Wait, push the blue off.
I'm done.
Wait, who's taking my box?
What?
Okay, okay.
You can take anybody's box?
Yeah, you can just...
You can just grab the...
Someone snobbitized me.
No, no.
I'm gonna go from the left.
Yeah.
Oh, the way your face matters.
You guys, the way your face matters.
Oh, that...
That makes all the difference.
I've gone responsibility.
If my box can't be where it belongs, nobody's box can be where it belongs.
You can write.
This is where my box is.
Okay.
This is where I am.
She was yelling in chat, where the fuck am I?
Oh, it's so over.
It's okay.
I'll move yours.
I need my box.
Guys, don't worry, Yellow.
I'm gonna do us a solid, okay?
Now, Yellow, you just have to come back here and stand behind the yellow...
Don't fucking me!
Wasn't yellow supposed to be...
Rin, I don't think your
box is supposed to be...
Oh!
Alright, this might be okay.
This might be good.
This might be it.
There's no way.
No, the box is out of position.
No, this might be okay.
This might be okay.
Trust.
Did we click it?
I just wanna be happy.
I'm up here.
My box needs to be down.
Okay.
I'll just go...
I'm here.
Nobody can move.
Box stay here.
Box stay there.
Hi, Mint.
Hi.
Thanks.
Thanks, slime.
You want it?
Let me push it over.
There you go.
There's your box.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
This has been the most teamwork I've ever seen.
Hold on!
I'm not ready!
Rin, help me out here.
What are we supposed to do?
What do we do here, bro?
Wait.
Is it here?
Is this right?
I don't know.
Where are you taking it?
I just put it there because I...
No!
Doki, you fucked my box!
That wasn't the right spot!
Doki!
I trusted you, Juniper!
I didn't know what I was supposed to do.
I thought you were doing something.
I was like, what?
Doki!
That's not my cool box!
I don't know!
Doki!
I think it was still
gone.
Oh, dear lord.
I thought you needed it.
You're freaking out!
Don't leave!
It's a box!
Everybody is moving my box!
Okay.
We're...
Click on your box!
Oh, wait!
Oh, no.
I wasn't paying attention.
I got you.
Your box is like here.
It's over.
I think that's why...
Can you just walk to me?
Can you just walk to the right, Doki?
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't move.
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, I'm done.
I can't move right now.
What are you doing?
I'm on my own!
Help me!
Help!
I need my...
It's a box!
Maybe you have the people with boxes who are your boss.
How about that?
You vacuumed me right at the end.
You put me out the way.
You put me out the way!
It's okay.
People with boxes, do your part!
Okay, no.
Okay, everybody with a box, move on.
Box gotta go down here.
And if you don't have a box, don't touch the other people's boxes.
Yeah, Doki!
Take your own advice!
Yeah, that's what I'm learning now!
Okay, we're good.
No, I need green!
I need green!
Push it down!
Don't push it down!
There you go!
Does anybody remember what pink was supposed to do?
Oh no!
Probably!
I look like I'm blinding you.
I'm totally face-locked.
Don't push!
Huh?
It had to go in the corner!
What do you mean it wasn't there?
It was locked the fucking door!
I'm blinding you now.
I'm blind!
I almost got it!
You almost had it!
You almost did!
I almost got it!
I almost did!
Okay, I'm locked in.
I'm locked in.
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
Alright, face into the right.
Face into the right.
Okay, I have a box.
I'm six.
Please let me go first.
I'm going to the left.
Okay, okay.
Stay here until 10 seconds left.
Please be kind.
I'm going to the left.
Guys, I feel like some people without boxes went up, guys.
Oh, my bad.
You're all for me!
Excuse me.
Pardon me.
Thank you.
I'm perfect.
Everything about my position and my box is perfect.
Do not touch it, please.
Thank you.
This is awkward.
How do I do this?
Here we go.
I'm here.
Don't touch mine.
We're here.
Jade, how do I...
It's over.
It's so over.
What happened?
What do you need?
I just... I don't know where to put the box now.
This is mine.
What's got up there?
I was so far away.
The box was at the third level.
I was supposed to be at the bottom.
She only gravitated up 18% of the wall.
I didn't even get up there.
I couldn't even jump.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I've got to go here.
Oh, my God.
Not again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Let us do anything.
Bao, if you need help, let me know.
Okay.
I'm down here with your... well, not with your box.
I could be...
The box?
Go first.
I am a box?
All right.
Hi-yah.
Okay.
Okay, I'm good.
Excuse me, Bao.
Are you okay over there with the box, people?
There we go.
The box is here.
Yay.
No, stop.
Please don't move my box.
I need the box.
What is it?
Let's do it again.
Yay.
Hello, darkness.
My old friend.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Bao, you can't hold your box.
Oh, gosh.
I like this song.
You can take the box and jump off to the bottom floor.
When I jump, it doesn't go away.
Oh, okay.
My box is here.
My box is almost in the same position.
Okay?
Just don't move my box.
I'll move it myself.
Wait.
Where am I?
Okay.
I'm up there.
All right.
It's fine.
Bao doesn't have to move a box.
It's on the third floor.
On the third floor.
Okay.
That's all I got to do.
Just make sure red gets out of the way.
That's all right.
That's it.
Don't move.
No, no, no.
Don't move it.
Watch out.
It's coming from my head.
Thank you.
Okay.
Leave it there.
Are we...
Wait.
I need to be in between.
Thank you.
No.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit.
Oh, is this it?
Oh, my God.
It's so close, but I don't think it's close enough, Rose.
I don't think it's close enough.
No, I think it is.
I think it is.
Trust.
I don't think it is.
Are you free?
I'm going to throw up.
This is it.
Yeah.
We made it out.
Yay.
We made it.
Let's go.
Yay.
I'm lying in your arms right now, dude.
So funny.
You can't take him with you.
Wait.
Hold on.
Okay.
There we go.
I was going to be like that.
I'm so fucked.
We can't get out.
Woohoo.
It hasn't even been two hours.
It's almost two hours and we completed three worlds out of thirteen.
That's good.
I agree.
We should open an academy.
Okay.
What is this?
What the fuck is this?
It's a marathon.
You must make a tower.
But don't touch the top.
Don't touch the top.
You'll die.
That's definitely not a trick.
That's a trick.
There's a trick.
You've been tricked.
I'm sorry.
Any skinny legends?
Time to take the easy way out.
How do we...?
I think you have to do it with as few people as possible.
So there's only one layer maybe.
I think only four people could fit.
Yes.
How do you still pass the key?
It was not...
I mean, I assume hopefully that the blocks will come back up when the water is done.
Yeah.
I think like there's like one person.
Like it goes...
Yeah, it lies.
It's just a population check.
A population check?
Yeah.
Population key grabbers.
We need one more over there.
I will make the sacrifice.
Go.
You got this.
Go four.
Okay.
Make a line.
Put line.
Yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Okay.
If this is wrong, then I guess you will die which sucks.
There's no way.
Shoot.
I'll miss you.
There's no way.
I know.
What the hell?
Because it can't kill you so you like stand in between.
Will you stand in between the thing?
I go down?
Oh, stand in between with the doors.
The doors.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
When they come down.
I go down.
Yeah, yeah.
So we need like...
Everybody then.
So we need standers.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was wondering why this level in an 8 player game was only made for 4 players.
Okay.
So we need one more.
We need one more.
Yeah.
To be up here.
We need another key grabber.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll go.
And then scoot down.
Scoot down.
And then you guys...
There we go.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Ready?
I'll just...
Yeah.
There we go.
All right.
You ready?
Position.
Perfect.
Okay.
Now run.
Go.
What the fuck do we do now?
What?
I can only talk.
Okay.
You're in this time, Emily.
And I'm here.
Team Geek annihilated.
I live.
Guys, have you subscribed?
Not mine?
Oh thanks for that.
You live in this room.
Yeah, that's huge.
You just messed up.
That's big.
Okay.
Everybody up.
I'll be at the last door.
No.
No, no, no.
I'll do it.
Toki, you know what?
I...
I can time this.
No, it's okay.
I'm sorry, but you'll be at the last door.
I don't want the pressure.
Oh, I closed up and fell.
Sorry.
Hi, Snappy.
Hi.
Okay, everybody.
Meow, meow.
Okay, we must...
Alright.
There we go, there we go.
Okay.
Alright.
We, we, we, we...
Okay, now.
Squinch.
Squinch, squinch, squinch.
Go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go.
Squinch, squinch, squinch.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Orange, orange.
Squinch, squinch, squinch.
Yeah.
Let's go.
I forgot what color I was for a second.
Can you please this color.
We need a little bit of excitement.
A little bit of suspense.
Oh, not you again.
Squinch, squinch, squinch.
Why is he not attached to anything?
Is this the first time they've shown up?
That's probably gonna fall off.
He turned into Sonic the Hedgehog!
I think we can stack it.
I think we should stack.
How?
One goes right and the other goes left?
Maybe?
He goes far.
He starts moving around like a pinball.
Yeah, it goes crazy.
We can all stack it up.
Wait, what's this over here?
What's this right here?
Pick the key.
Oh, there's another one!
Okay, so...
They can't go past that, which is good.
They go right first.
So maybe like...
Whoops!
I see, I see!
One person goes up and gets the key.
Wait, actually, no.
Because then it goes back to us.
Can we see what the box does first?
Yeah, yeah, let's see what the box does.
Don't touch the key.
Just run, yeah.
We all push it, yeah.
Okay, who?
You traitor!
Okay.
Alright.
We push the box.
Nobody jump, guys.
I know it's very tempting.
Wait, wait, wait!
No, that's not gonna help.
Okay, okay.
What if we push it this way?
And then we push the sword away from the door.
And this one is for the other one that comes down.
Oh, I see.
This way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push it closer to us.
Here, hold on.
Push it like...
Yes.
I don't know where the other saw spawns, right?
Okay, one of you guys get it then.
One of you guys get the key.
No, no, no!
We can push it towards the key.
Oh, I see.
It's to block it.
Got it, got it, got it.
It's to block the blades.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't jump, guys, don't jump.
It's so tempting.
Don't tell me what to do.
We still have to get that one block, guys.
There you go, there you go.
Nice.
Alright, I am gonna push to the left.
Push everybody.
Pass where the key is, I think, right?
I don't know.
Okay.
Alright, yeah, pass where the key...
I think pass the door.
No, no, we want it here.
Yeah, yeah.
Grab the key, it'll bounce on the block and then we get it to safety.
Now keep pushing it.
No, keep pushing it.
Keep pushing it and it can't go past the block, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We're so smart, guys.
Let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep pushing.
Okay.
Now just keep the key.
Yeah, yeah.
Alright, pass the key.
Oh, oh, oh.
There, there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a team effort.
Yay!
We did it!
We're victorious.
Yippee!
Oh, World 3?
Alright, here we go.
This is so easy.
Oh, never mind.
What?
We gotta stack, we gotta stack.
And not get hit.
Okay, I got hit.
I need to see where I spawn first.
This is so fast.
What the hell?
If we don't move, does it start?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are you sure?
No, I think if we just stand there.
Don't move, don't move.
Don't touch your keyboard.
We'll see.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, we just gotta dodge all of them.
Oh, oh my god.
They keep falling.
What the hell?
Okay.
That's how it falls.
Oh, okay.
I sacrificed someone.
This one is something.
Yeah, this is messed up.
Oh, yo, we killed it.
We almost figured it out.
We also killed three people.
I need to jump through the key.
Oh my god, timing sucks.
Well, I mean, we can get the key afterwards.
We can get the key afterwards by stacking.
Yeah, yeah, I don't think we have to die.
I know where I have to go.
You guys gotta figure out where you have to land.
That was the safest.
I just have to move, like, a little.
I just have to... oh, whoops.
Ouch.
I just have to move a little bit.
My big head.
Oh, never mind.
Don't be sure you know where to go.
Kind of, maybe.
Okay.
Oh, yo, yo, yo.
Okay, it was just me, so I didn't fuck it up.
You were so close.
Hmm.
Now move over.
I gotta, like, jump and then hang really far to the left, I guess?
Or can I jump over it?
I'm not even drawing these three seconds of music.
Rin, do you want to be the one to be on the bottom?
Or do you want me to be?
There you go, there you go.
Okay, you got it.
We can't fuck this up.
Yes, we can.
We will.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
There we go.
We can't fuck this up.
Just don't jump in the hole.
I'm alive.
Until you're in there.
Okay.
We actually did that surprisingly very quickly the next day.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Maybe I lost one, so let's pray.
Okay, okay.
Let's all just pray.
Just because you said that?
For me, it's what I am.
I'm not meant to be used like this.
We spawned it differently.
Okay.
One at a time.
This has to be one at a time here.
Very carefully, yes.
Only one person can go through per line.
Or not.
I thought I could fall through.
Okay.
The people at the B part can just run off.
Yeah.
You guys can just run.
Oh, fuck.
I think you have to wait until we're off of it before you go forward.
I'm trapped in my confines.
I'll go get the key here.
Okay, you guys can go off with the next one.
Alright, and then you wait.
Oh, we go?
And then now you go.
Oh, sorry.
It's a little bit delicate.
Very delicate.
Alright.
Okay, I'll get the key, maybe.
I don't know, actually.
I'm scared.
Okay,
Bow, you gotta move forward, Bow.
I don't wanna.
It's okay.
Okay, we can do this.
I trusted you.
You nestled in my dent and I betrayed you, I'm sorry.
Ah, fuck, bitch!
So excited.
Okay.
Oh, sorry, sorry!
I saw a Stuffy jumping and I also wanted to join!
Bow!
Before I locked the door.
I saw a Stuffy jumping and I wanted to join.
My turn!
One person get the key, go unlock the door.
Okay, here I'll go.
I swear my brain is fucking slurry right now.
Nobody else knows except for Doki.
I trust Bow.
I didn't even finish the sentence yet.
Ta-da!
Okay.
Oh, we're playing froggy now.
Holy shit.
Here we go.
Nobody else can.
That was all me, baby.
We can stack, guys.
You don't have to do it by two, guys.
You guys can stack over there.
I'm just not gonna move.
Oh, are you guys coming with Pinky?
Oh my god.
Whoa, whoa, okay.
Okay, okay.
I got the key!
Wait, but, wait, but...
No one's got the key.
It's so small!
Not anymore, man.
Not anymore.
It might be safer to just go through individually.
Okay.
That's too much risk.
I know, it's too much.
That's like five times more risk.
That's too much.
We just need trusted people to be the bottoms.
Yeah, designated bottoms.
Designated bottoms.
Designated bottoms who haven't died yet to the lines.
I've never died.
Pretty much everybody, I think.
Okay, all right.
You can't be a top.
All right.
I nominate Lime to be one of the designated bottoms.
Oh, sorry.
That was me acting out because I wasn't a bottom.
It's so funny that Dot cannot be a bottom anymore.
What the heck, man?
Let's stack, girls.
All right, stack time.
Snuffy, I think we can fit one more.
Oh.
All right, here we go.
We can remake the bottom.
We can remake it.
I don't know if...
Let's just go with that.
Let's see.
Are we feeling okay?
How are we doing up there, Val?
I haven't moved for so long, I forgot what...
Oh, sorry.
How are we going to get through the lasers at the end, bro?
I can't introduce...
You know what?
I'm going to stop.
I apologize.
Do you?
Do you mean that?
Are you okay?
I'll be waiting for four more.
I apologize to every single one of you on my death by next time.
What the?
Everybody gets one.
That was my one.
Shut up!
That was my first time!
Congrats.
I don't want to get the key anymore.
Someone else can.
I got this.
I feel like our power is leaning a little bit too far to the right.
All right.
Yeah, this is better, this is better.
All right, you guys can go.
They don't even look like cabin lockdowns.
Oh, no.
All right.
See you, Doki.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Guys,
guys, I've had a revelation.
Here, get on me.
The taller the towers are, the easier it is to align them with the green cubes.
Yes, exactly.
There we go.
Okay.
Wait, Bao, can you inch over so that you're...
Yeah, yeah.
Why doesn't the key...
If it touches it, it doesn't matter.
I don't trust any of you.
Oh, my God, oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
It was such a small margin.
I know.
We have to be perfectly lined up.
That's what I was...
Be so perfect.
Make sure that your bottom and my bottom are lined.
All right, here we go.
You can line them up with the feet in the air.
That's not what I meant.
You guys go forward first just in case we do all that and then we die.
I don't appreciate how that tower is leaning.
Okay.
I'm trying.
Well, sometimes you're going to live in such situations.
I realized it as I said it.
All right, here we go.
Oh, God, oh, God.
Orange, orange, get them together.
I'm trying.
I want to join in.
Oh, Lord.
Green and red.
I believe.
That's pretty.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Jump on, Snuffy.
Oh, I don't think she's going to get on.
It's all on her right now.
How is Snuffy supposed to jump on?
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God, oh, my God.
I can't watch.
I'm watching.
If she dies, I'll remember her face.
The last...
Yeah!
Okay, do it.
Final challenge.
Get through the door.
I will be power bottom.
We're so good.
I'm so proud of all of you.
We did it.
Oh, my God.
You guys, I was shrimping so hard over my keyboard.
Permanent spinal damage from this one.
Why is that one so ominous?
Like, what the heck?
Just do this.
This one should be our last one.
It says special park.
What makes it so special?
Okay, just one level.
I'm getting up from my seat and I'm leaving physically.
Okay, what makes it so special?
Oh, one.
It's Russian roulette.
Oh, my God.
So, you get to pick.
Oh, my God, it's squid game.
Oh, this is actually messed up.
It's so special.
Oh, this one's fun.
Okay.
Oh, God.
The pressure.
The pressure, the pressure.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I didn't...
One.
This is my luck.
What the hell?
Just do it again.
Just get it right.
Okay.
You just won.
This is evil.
This is an evil game.
Oh, hey, guys.
We're doing really well.
Now, this is what I call Pico Park 2.
Oh, no.
Please.
Oh, my God.
No pressure.
It's like a 50-50 chance.
You win these.
There's like so many buttons.
It's okay.
All right.
Yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
This one next to me.
Okay.
Just kidding.
We're okay.
It's like a three out of five chance.
You got this.
It's that one.
Okay, good.
Doki, please.
Doki.
I can't walk.
I cannot walk.
Doki, please.
I can't walk.
I thought
they were deactivated.
Why do you think that the game would be nice to us?
What do you want?
Oh,
that means that everything matters.
No way.
I thought it wasn't going to be active anymore.
I saw the fucking buttons weren't pressed right before min 1 and I was like they wouldn't.
They fucking didn't.
Are you kidding me?
That's totally crazy.
I was like so happy.
I was like half popping along.
Just like living my life.
You were so happy you started glowing.
I was like, no.
Doki!
There's no way min hits the first one.
Yeah, there's no way.
Right, right, right.
Is it this one?
This one, this one, this one.
Pick this one.
This one's okay.
That one's okay.
Alright, I'm going to pick this one.
On your advice.
Yeah.
One out of ten chance.
That's why I don't go to the...
That's why I didn't trust you.
This one's safe, I swear.
I swear this one's safe.
Oh my god.
Good vibes on this one.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm not fucking around.
I'm just going for the one near to the door.
If I can get down, please.
Okay, I want to get the clue.
I'm hearing this fucking song in my sleep.
There we go.
Are you having fun yet?
Oh god.
Oh, it's just... oh no.
It's okay.
Let's go gambling.
Aw, dang it.
Oh no.
Why am I last?
No pressure or anything.
No.
Alright.
This one's all good.
The one near is the door.
Okay, yeah.
I'll go for this one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we can all walk there.
So we all know it's safe.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I like how we all waited to see it.
Yippee.
Ow.
Alright.
Yay.
We did it.
No more.
I'm so proud of us.
Who said this game doesn't stop until we do all 13 levels?
A psycho.
You're sick in the head.
Some of us have families, okay?
Imagine if we had to listen to that soundtrack for two more hours.
Imagine if we had to do that.
Even more than two hours, I think.
I can keep going.
We might as well just finish the game.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I can keep going too.
Alright.
Can we actually finish this game?
Oh yeah.
I think we can.
I thought we were meant to be friends.
Well, we're not quitters.
90% of gamblers lose before they win big.
Endurance scream.
Unfortunately for 10% of gamblers, it is their bedtime now, so...
Good night, gamblers.
Good night.
I'm still here, dammit!
Good night, old man.
Good night.
Kids these days, honestly.
God.
Alright.
Are we actually completing this game?
I'm down.
Wait, are we actually?
Are we actually?
We can do it another day, right?
You know, for the sake of our brains, right?
If we're gonna do another day, you have to be there till the very end.
Okay.
You have to...
Or John Pico will come to your house and...
Oh my god, send this to five of your friends.
Or John Pico will come through your window.
We will schedule Pico Park 2 and we're going...
Pico Park 2 2.
And we have to do it until we finish.
We have to do our entire schedule just for this game.
The entire day.
Entire day, just to finish this game.
Yes, the drills.
Okay.
No food.
It's literally torture.
Until you beat the game.
You get 15 minutes bathroom break.
You gotta hold it until we beat it.
We'll ship everyone a special...
The only pee you can have is Pico Park.
Park 2.
Woo!
If you didn't get a gamer bottle, you're not committed.
Everyone's shipped a special gamer chair.
With holes.
You get one meal and one plastic bottle.
Sit the hell down.
This is worse than the Marines.
Part 2 is going to be an endurance stream.
We're all committed, right?
Yeah.
In a horrifying way, yes.
We're all in a blood pack.
We cannot leave.
I hope you guys have your rabies shot.
I hope we can start a little earlier than 11pm, Michael.
If we end, if it takes us six hours, it'll take us six hours, but we'll all be here.
If we hate each other by the end of it, then that's just a sacrifice we gotta be willing to make.
A flow of poison is slowly dripping into our veins, and we have to beat it before the time limit.
We're gonna make a saw event out of this.
I mean, that's basically peek-a-part.
Alright, GG's, everybody.
GG for all of you guys for the game.
Thank you for playing.
So fun.
GG.
Bye-bye.
GG's every- oh.
People are still in the game.
What if I click on it?
Oh, it doesn't do anything.
Oh, they're slowly filing out.
Leave game.
That was craziness!
My brain hurts just a little bit, but that was so much fun!
Oh, peek-a-part.
I'm just gonna close out of that.
And save us all.
The, um...
The...
The torture.
Oh, I was really nervous, though.
So many people I've never collabed with.
I hope you guys had fun, even though it was probably kind of crazy.
And everybody was bleh-bleh-bleh.
I didn't even have a chance to ask you guys if the audio was okay.
If the audio was bad, I'm so sorry.
I was like mid-trying to adjust everything all within time.
I was like oh god.
That was good?
Okay, good.
Yippee!
My brain is fried.
Can everyone come back?
Y'all never did introductions.
Well, I think they've all collabed before except me.
So...
Throw this guy away.
Get out of here.
Get out of here, Pico Park.
John Pico.
Parked right there on my head.
I can do an introduction right now.
Hello!
Welcome back!
My name is Mint Phantom.
I'm a ghost made Vtuber.
And...
Um...
Don't let me push the last button!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Did you have fun?
I did!
I had so much fun!
I had a good time.
I hope you guys did too.
Now I'm hearing the Pico music in your BGM.
Okay, let's change it.
Let's change it.
Everything I have reminds me of him.
John Pico!
I like the Metal Gear level.
That one was really good.
I liked the button one so much.
The Russian roulette one.
Introducing Mint Phantom as the new guy!
That was so much fun!
Oh, Pico Park.
Now we're gonna have to do an endurance of the Pico Park.
You were cool?
Everything was fine?
Okay.
I'm cool.
I'm fine.
It's good to...
We kind of met up right before the stream started too so I didn't get much time to talk to everybody.
But it was all just chaos.
And you know what?
That's basically trauma bonding.
So, how's your sanity?
Like I said, I could've kept going.
I'm here.
I'm stable.
Surprisingly.
But next time?
I don't know.
Who knows what will happen.
It's so cool to see you and Lime in the same stream.
Yeah!
Lime is so nice.
I really like her.
I wanna collab with her.
Nah.
I wanna do a collab.
Maybe like one-on-one or like a small group or something, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was something Lime was just like Once you beat this game, you must talk to me.
What was it?
I can't remember.
Ghost Trick!
Yes!
I think it was Ghost Trick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hope you can collab with everyone again.
Yeah!
Ask her now.
What do you mean ask her now?
She's not here.
She's gone.
Lime has always just been in your head.
But if you lost sanity with this, oh boy you're gonna be in for a treat with the collab that Doki and I are planning.
Once I'm back from Japan You're a suit.
You're a suit.
Yes, yes.
Thank you for the donuts!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, there was some that I missed.
I'm sorry.
Cowabunga roll.
Jin, thank you!
Shantae.
I love Shantae!
Thank you so much.
Ray, thank you.
Thank you for the good company on my birthday.
Happy birthday, Ray!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Ray.
Happy birthday!
Thank you guys for the gift and memberships.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, angel.
Thank you guys.
Lime plus minto equals mojito.
What's in a mojito?
Lime and mint?
Yes!
And rum.
What's a rum taste like?
Babycore, thanks for the gift!
I did it!
Should I try a mojito?
Firewater.
I thought it's...
Spicy?
But is it fine with the lime and the mint?
There's also white rum.
Rum can be brown.
The syrup takes the edge off.
Wait, that doesn't sound like just rum and lime and mint.
Now you're saying there's syrup too?
The only thing I know about rum is Pirates of the Caribbean.
And I don't know, it's always gone.
Apparently.
Allegedly.
Simple syrup.
Well, that's just rude.
Why can't it be intellectual syrup?
I don't know.
You can't just call the syrup simple.
Incredible comedic timing.
What?
Thanks for the fun collab!
So same time next week?
I don't know about that.
Because it gets too fancy if it's intellectual.
People like it simple.
What's that saying?
Kiss.
Keep it simple, stupid.
But my name's not...
stupid.
Thank you!
What do you mean?
What does rum taste like?
As a bartender, I feel attacked.
I don't drink!
Kiss him.
No!
Keep it stupid simple.
How simple do you want water and sugar to be?
Is that the syrup?
I guess that's pretty simple.
Then is it kiss him keep it sexy mint?
No!
Sexy!
You guys, keep it sexy.
Where is the sex?
I have no sex appeal.
What are you talking about?
Do you want a map?
You are literally making a document.
It's not my fault.
It's not my fault people draw me that way.
Oh my gosh, I'm basically Jessica Rabbit.
This tattoo for some reason has inspired me.
And I'll eventually get around to commissioning Brazilian mint.
Do whatever floats your boat.
I got a mint cake fan art.
That says otherwise.
We saw the forbidden ducky, don't lie.
It's Isekai!
It's Isekai.
It's a different world.
Mint from a different world.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks, Tri-Princess!
Jessica Ghost.
Yeah.
No, Jessica... Isn't...
So, Roger Rabbit is the last name.
Or, Rabbit's the last name.
So, Jessica Rabbit.
She's married to Roger Rabbit.
She took his last name, so she's Jessica Rabbit.
So, I would be Jessica Phantom.
Oh my god, that means Jessica Rabbit married me instead!
It all works out.
Hahaha.
The moles are the moi moi magic, Pinto.
Don't look at my moles.
Roger Phantom.
No.
That guy is not involved.
Are you playing patty cake with another rabbit's wife?
Bakersman?
Bake me a cake?
As fast as you can!
Just talk MGS to us to be sexy.
Okay, so...
Solid Snake and his brother, Liquid Snake, are at each other's throats.
And one thinks that they're inferior than the other.
Yeah, you like that?
And then there's not a gaseous snake, but there's a solidus.
And that guy is the third other brother.
The brother that, I guess, they didn't know about and they had to insert into the story.
I'm all hot and bothered.
Plasma Snake!
They're brothers?
Oh my gosh, it's exactly like a romance novel.
There's always got to be brothers.
Hahaha.
It's always got to be brothers.
Claire, thank you so much for five months!
Oh, sorry, they were typing in the Discord.
We're Splendid Nova, thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you!
Lambda Delta, thank you for five months!
It was very fun, Minto.
Going to bed now, goodnight.
Goodnight!
I guess I'll head out to...
I guess I'll go...
Tomorrow I have a mid-day stream for me, so...
Probably better for me to...
Get some sleep...
Get some stuff done and get some sleep...
Better be playing Minecraft...
Oh my gosh.
Better be playing Minecraft.
I
haven't played Minecraft in so long, I probably don't know how to play anymore.
I probably don't know how to play anymore.
Speaking of sexy...
Slash, in your sexy voice say that my phone is ringing and I should really pick up the phone.
You want me to say that?
Your phone is ringing!
Oh my God!
You gotta pick up the phone!
Or else...
The call's gonna hang up.
Oh my God!
Pick up the phone!
Your phone's ringing.
Too late!
Call ended.
Maybe I should have done it without the BGM.
Close enough.
What do we say in the Frogbear voice?
Oh.
Okay, here's a phone ringtone for all you sexy persons out there.
Okay, um...
Hey there, this is your buddy Frogbert.
And if you're hearing my voice right now, you could probably guess what that means.
But I'll let you have three guesses.
Yeah, we can play a game of like three questions.
I was gonna say ten questions, but then probably the call will end by then.
So, you better be ready.
You might wanna like pick up your phone...
Oh wait, you have to guess why you're hearing my voice.
Hold on, I messed up.
I messed it
up, you guys.
I missed the low voice you would do.
What?
If you don't like my voice, you don't have to listen to me.
You don't have to watch.
You know?
I don't know.
If you don't like my voice...
It's okay.
I get it.
I'm hearing that ringtone out in the wild.
Does anyone ever actually have a ringtone on?
I never have had...
I don't know the last time I've had a ringtone on.
Because...
Like even a text alert or anything like that...
I just...
Because of work, I just never had one on.
You never know who might call.
Always on vibrate.
Yeah, see?
Mine's always on vibrate too.
Not like 10 years...
Yeah!
Mine's always on vibrate.
I think it's because I usually have my phone on me.
So if someone calls, I don't have to hear it.
I can just...
I'll just see it.
Like...
Oh!
I'm getting a call.
Of the MGS codec call.
I want that for like my text sound.
Hearing a phone ring makes me anxious.
I don't know.
Like yeah.
Even in public, I only hear like boomers with their...
It's always like that...
It's always like that iPhone ringtone.
That's just like a...
Sounds like a regular...
A regular...
Um...
Phone ringing.
My text alert is the MGS.
Woop!
And my ringer is the codec sound.
I never turn that shit off.
I...
You are...
You...
What?
How can you...
How can you function hearing that alert sound?
And then like...
Not...
Having the most anxiety in your life.
How?
I don't know.
Why do they always speak on speakerphone?
Phone bad.
Phone scary.
So true.
I don't know.
Maybe I should get a ringtone.
I don't really get any texts from people.
I usually only get texts from like...
The doctor's office.
Or something.
I don't really get texts.
Nah.
Maybe an idol song.
As my ringtone?
Nah.
I think I would want Metal Gear.
Yeah.
We'll text you.
You will?
I wonder if it would work for like...
For like...
Oh gosh.
If it was for...
Twitter notifications.
I would be getting a bajillion.
If it also worked for that too.
You'll never miss a call or text.
Well guys.
Actually.
I'm gonna go get...
Some din...
Din...
Dinner.
I had the chocobo chirp as a notification sound for my last phone before.
I had to upgrade.
For my current one.
I don't know what to use.
Why don't you use the same one?
If you liked it.
Ghost offering.
I don't know.
I don't know why my last...
Don't know.
Didn't go through.
But I tried to say that.
If you...
Were into video essays.
Second one.
Just made a new one.
I'm on MGS.
Oh.
Thanks.
I'd rather not.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Yeah.
I think I'm gonna go get some dinner.
And...
I want Taco Bell.
Taco Bell.
But I was cleaning earlier.
And I lost track of time.
And I was like.
Oh, I'm gonna go get Taco Bell.
But then...
But then it was time for the coollwooow.
I've been thinking about it this whole time.
I was like I really just want Taco Bell.
For a second I though you'd rather not check out the video.
Nooo.
We had Taco Bell today because I ate a hamburger?
I'm at Taco Bell in like so long.
I think like two months.
So I'm like, okay time for my like...
Buy... what's the word?
Buy monthly Taco Bell.
What should I get though?
What should I get?
Do they have Taco Bell in Japan?
They do.
But why would I go get Taco Bell in Japan?
The only fast food place I'll go to in Japan is really just Wendy's.
Because I like their fries.
The first kitchen fries.
But if I can't help it, I don't go to like any of them.
Except like, well you know, like McDonald's or Burger King or KFC or those ones, you know.
Taco Bell in Japan is kind of sad?
No way, really?
Imagine if they have Culver's in Japan.
I don't know the last time I had Culver's either.
Long, long time ago.
Quesalupa and Quesadilla Funs.
Thanks!
The wet box?
The carvings box?
With the Chalupa Supreme and the beefy... I love beefy five layer.
I love beefy five layer!
Now I want Taco Bell.
Let's all go get Taco Bell together, okay?
Okay, group wisp outing.
We're all gonna go get Taco Bell.
Okay.
I don't have Taco Bell near me.
Actually, that's also part of the way...
uh
Part of why I didn't get a Porsche.
Street 2, because my Taco Bell is kind of far.
I have to go.
BP5 later, burrito fun.
It's my fave.
Two ashes!
Stop being so based.
Oh my god.
I love BP5 later.
I love the cheese in it.
It's so yummy.
Stop, I can't.
Okay, I need to stop thinking about Taco Bell.
I didn't realize it was Taco Tuesday.
Absolutely!
Oh, it really is Tuesday.
It's Tuesday and...
What am I doing?
Tomorrow's...
Tomorrow is Minecraft.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, why didn't I fill in my calendar?
I just put stream, stream, stream.
Stream, stream.
Oh, okay, okay.
It's Tuesday.
Instinct9, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I'm so hungry.
Okay, let's go eat.
Okay.
I'm tasty s'more.
It's dinner time, isn't it?
It's not time for dessert.
Why are you guys sending all these super chats?
What are you guys doing?
Why, why, why, why, why, why?
I'm right here.
Rules are meant to be broken.
So true.
Super chat time.
No!
I'm right here.
Aren't those supposed to be when I go pee?
It simulates the flush.
It encourages me to flush the toilet.
Taco bell.
Oh, thanks for the new ringtone.
Thanks!
Oh, wait.
Some of these are kind of backed up.
Sorry.
Arigato, arigato.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
And wash your hands.
I always wash my hands.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not a fiend.
I don't know why I don't know how to end the stream.
Maybe because it was collab.
I didn't get to talk to you guys much, so I want to talk.
But I'll talk to you guys a lot tomorrow.
Right?
I'll see you tomorrow?
Really?
She loves us.
Don't get the wrong idea!
Yeah!
That's not even a little bit.
Look at how angry I am when you make false, when you, when you assume things incorrectly.
I just have a lot to say.
I have so many words.
And I didn't get, I didn't, I didn't have a chance to say all my words.
So I have to say them now.
I have to get all of them out.
It's not because it's you.
It's because I have too many words.
This is so disgusting.
I'm leaving.
Bye bye.
Itterashai.
Otomito.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Otomito.